okay so this is slow love and I have
seen slug love and that is bad it sounds
like the end of Return of the Jedi snug
now it's all about t'get it's a slow
love is awesome it's also awesome
Sanofi trouble celebrates a girl
no wonder when I start any rendition of
love love I have to keep going I'm sorry
blah blah know love love it's from the
end of attendance that you are it's from
Yo no Yo no no it's yup no do you speak
fluent II walk ease or something as I
saw two slugs making out take it left
Robb's slug of phobic thing going on
here obviously you can't take two slugs
yes because I love burritos
just because I see it as a sin in the
eyes of God does not mean my hunky slow
no but you know a goose and uh you know
Fox kissing it's perfect oh well that's
natural I really get disturbed by all
the anti slug love like signs and that
church yeah I'm still gonna enjoy my
slug fillet okay there's nothing wrong
with eating in mu care yeah yeah marry
them you know and Duke when we don't
want any of them alive but just don't
kiss whoa is that what you're saying too
far or not far enough
not too far this is slow love and it's
it's a story about a slug in a snail and
the slug is gigantic and looking for a
girlfriend so
Finn and Jake a opamp but turns out he's
a slug and any fine it's a slug that
thought which she was a snail but was
she was just attached to a peppermint
and then they hook up and they kiss but
it's always seen in the eyes of God
anyway so of course if we used to say no
more room in heaven for me honestly I I
thought this was just okay honestly uh
the only reason I can say it I think is
because so are the times you just that
is gets
I think it's crushed in the opening when
they throw to the side and the difícil
comes in poor fimo there was a really
good lead of joke would be though that I
loved it's like wait he went uh he's
trying to play beemo that's a live game
boy for those of us they're just not a
game boy okay okay what is BMO Z BMO
well does anyone saw that coming so Jake
s4 so kindly asked for the newspaper
that he was reading and just sits there
slowly you see coming from a mile away
just beat I think you wanted to do that
with your own computer but am I the only
one who thinks that the slug is slurms
mckenzie in his retirement day it
doesn't the future on you this is nobody
else at know I saw it
how can you see it I saw slugs fucking
today through the context man read
through the lines it's all metaphor
everything in the slug Bible says Venice
or our sly bolt the sly I just really
liked how all the shells on the snails
head butts yeah and apparently snail
boobies is now if I hey I think we're
just got they said animals Java boobies
yeah I guess so not till they can you
draw ones with retractable penises and
stuff why not we have to accept actually
most kind of technically do have a
retractable penis maybe that's the
explanation in the Looney Tunes like
maybe do have junk it's just all hidden
inside well that's well obviously yeah
that's if you look at an animal what's
there is not technically the
what comes out of it that red thing that
Jason's done a lot of animal
experimentation in his day and awkward
stare no I mean that's a judgmental
stare no it's creeping me out to the
camera just away from Jason what does
one say to this I know I said I thought
it's just okay wait you think Jason talk
without penis if you can well the window
penis isn't here would be very easy for
you to do no no I no pun intended I do
agreed it was a quite slow episode um I
was not a huge fan of the snail
character anyways snail slug character
anyways not likable not hateable he was
just kind of yeah every time they said
like you know oh but we'll help him out
us are like yeah I'm not getting that
vibe of the oh he's so cute we want to
help him yeah but I did like when Jake
first played the female snail and then
played the mail snail then he's like
kept switching between the that was good
I really liked that have a deeper and I
to this being what the forth episode yes
yeah yeah um it's a it was okay yeah the
randomness was definitely interesting
but not as much it was replaced though
by metaphors that are quite frankly
disturbing
there is sad juice which I will let
people discover for themselves and then
at the very end with also making out and
you know it's like okay they're just
making out you know maybe it's not gonna
go too far B mode the creature that was
being beat up on the entire episode they
get spilled entirely with this I juice
that was unseemly even I'm against
just be sad Jews say the creepiest part
about it was actually be most watching
making out that was just someone gotta
be looking you like not disturb really I
never thought about these sick the sick
context here but yeah now I can't stop
it yeah yes because I cannot be a you
know I'm not gonna say watching two
slugs making out is more freakish than
watching faces of death while dropping
acid but don't ever do that again
Cartoon Network no okay
don't ever do that again but you've told
that are disturbing than the one snail
being grinded on by like a dozen female
snails oh man that was yeah when they
lock lips that was nasty
the lovers happy juice some really great
lines though
you smell like cupcakes and rainbows
like what was that like an Amish snail
that he comes across the second one
behead like the father
like they all have like kind of foreign
accents yeah Jenna was fine I did like
when Jake blows the one tiny little
grain of salt on them and it hits and it
just goes so yeah okay episode all
around
okay this couch is a bit 2pac and we can
get rid of a few people off this couch
for next time at least no I think Jason
needs a hug come on guys give them uh
wait a minute
slug sex that's animal power I love good
dreams tonight